of peace peace be with you thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the dean
show
islam is built on the five pillars that
you worship none but the creator of the
heavens and earth that you establish a
direct dial-up connection with the five
times a day pay the charity to the poor
do fast during the month of ramadan and
do the hajj the pilgrimage to the first
house of worship
built by abraham and
from there you're constantly striving to
be the best human being that you can be
but you need your other half
and half your deen half your way of life
is when you find that other half that
man or that woman you come together
you're not
being out there promiscuous
you're not being out there dating boys
and girls and doing all these things
that are not pleasing to the creator you
came together and you got married so we
want you to stay together sometimes
there's fights
and when there are are you fighting
within the perimeters of islam the way
that's pleasing to the creator are you
fighting fair we got all these questions
and more that we're going to be asking
our next guest here on the dean's show
don't go nowhere we'll be right back
this is
20 years 20 years you've been helping
people stay together
instead of
letting them dissolve relationships that
took years to build
you've been you're with the isla you're
the director of the islamic circ center
of canada
religious affairs you're also for public
relations the director for mercy mission
islam is a merciful religion it's a
mercy mission is that our mission of
mercy what is this you got it we're on
the mission one of the mercy missions
mercy mission so this topic now that
we're talking about marriage is it true
i open the show is this half your dean
and when we say dean what do we mean
half of our deen meaning the deen is
really everything that you do according
to the scholars is uh the amana a man is
what you're entrusted with nadine is a
debt definition of uh linguistically but
is what you owe allah subhanahu ta'ala
who are the slaves of allah subhanahu
ta'ala
so now
when you get together in marriage
is there such a thing as boyfriend and
girlfriend islam you know you test drive
a little bit hang out you know get your
own apartment and just test the waters
and it doesn't work out switch go to the
next
or you know marriage is the key if you
want to get together with man and woman
right before i get to digging
you know uh pressing on some other
very important questions there is there
is such a thing as a boyfriend and
girlfriend in islam i know you're
shocked but we'll call that halal
boyfriend and a halal girlfriend
permissible permissible under the
pretense of being engaged of course with
the mahram and so on so islam does not
deprive you the uh the opportunity of
getting to know one another before you
get married so it's not a surprise
or something that you have no choice
before you get married
of course there are steps that we ask
the brothers and sisters to do if we
have the time and the and the opinion
comes up we will tell them what to do
before you get married but are we
allowed to get to know one another yes
but boyfriend and girlfriend as we know
it here in the west of course not but we
turn that into a positive we say we do
have a halal boyfriend and girlfriend
and insha allah permissible under an
engagement with the mahram insha allah
where there is no we're not sitting
together alone i'm not talking about
just physically also on the phone and
chatting and insha allah you'll you'll
understand what i mean by that now again
just one more thing i just remember i
got an email i got an email from someone
and they said that you know everything
about islam makes sense but i just can't
wrap my my mind around you know not
being able to date i can't rep my it
doesn't make sense how we supposed to
get to know each other before we get
married then you don't like someone and
then you got married and now it's too
late you're married what do you tell the
people you deal a lot with the youth and
and you're asked these questions i'm
sure all the time how do you answer it
it's the number one question we get the
gender relations what can we do what can
we do can i have a boyfriend can i have
a girlfriend which is really normal
because this is what prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi said the biggest
fitnah that i fear that i've vet with
you is women so i understand how the
brothers feel been there done that we're
not going to deploy him and islam does
not deny the fact that you should have a
beautiful wife or you should get to know
one with the intention of getting to
know you know do it but let's do it
properly now we don't do it like knock
on the door and
rapunzel throw down your hair and you
know there's a samson delilah romy
go sing and stories and all that stuff
these are fictions we we stick to our
quran and sundance
so islam does provide you with that but
how do you do it is the proper way to do
it knock on the door
you know and come to the homes according
to the quran through the gate through
the door not the back tower
or the window for sure so coming through
the front door absolutely that's the
right way and islam lays all this out
absolutely it's in the quran sunnah and
we've been taught how to do this long
time ago and the simple fact is that if
you put yourself in the father's
position yeah you see the differences
the father comes in a man comes
up to you knock on the door
he says i want to marry your your
daughter he will open up the door he
will tell people about it but if you uh
come from the back door nobody will tell
anything about it you'll be ashamed of
it you won't tell anybody about it so
there is a major difference the same as
a cat yeah you give her a piece of uh
food he will eat in front of you but if
she steals it he will catch it and run
away so let's do the right thing and
build the relationship and build your
home uh and build your your marital
relationship on the proper way to become
a strong foundation as opposed to you
playing you're paying the price later
well i had a couple in my office that
said i want a divorce the wife wanted to
divorce the the brother and we asked her
why says because we had a
you know previous relations
inappropriate relations before
the marriage and she couldn't see the
brother anymore to be uh you know uh
trustworthy that you know he couldn't do
things the proper way and didn't do it
according to quran sunnah so now she
disrespects him and doesn't want to stay
with him anymore so you know whether we
like it or not we have to please allah
subhana wa
our relationship in the proper way to
please god almighty and of course we
don't worry about the people because if
you please god almighty allah will be
pleased with you and force people to be
pleased with you too and i certainly
tell the the opposite is true of course
and i tell the sisters please don't be a
statistic
if the brothers ask you need to do
things behind your father's back he's
not i mean he's not trustworthy he's not
the one that you want to spend the rest
of your life with
though he knows already that he this is
wrong it's a behavioral issue and we
know that the
being uh doing all these things
is not permissible is unlawful so now
the brother has no religious backgrounds
and among the conditions of prophet
muhammad salla sallam is as he says he
has to have holocaust he has to have
moral contact and he has to have a
religious background so if he doesn't
have the religious backgrounds and
trying to play hooky and you know
whatever it may take we say that brother
is not the right brother that you want
to be with
this is amazing amazing because you know
again before we get to the main topic
this is
usually the agenda of man the guy
doesn't have that fear of the crate of
the heavens and earth he's trying to get
something that you know uh you can only
have in marriage and women get naive a
lot of times don't they and they listen
to these sweet words and next to you
know you're just a statistic like you
said used in abuse your yesterday's
newspaper it's old and he's had its fun
and you've been just
a number now exactly
the reason
we say this is
when you look at the research you'll
find out that men are physically based
women are emotionally based so if a
brother has a little bit of a sweet you
know
talking you know groovy and all that the
guys know like he knows what to say the
he will say you know i love you honey
and all these things and all of a sudden
the sister goes ah
you know she wipes out and i'm yours
and we you know he's got her and that's
what we say you know protect yourself
we're saying that this is a brother
you know what you do will be done unto
you right you may have a sister your
your own daughter
somebody will do the same thing on to
you if you don't want anybody to do that
to your own daughter or your own wife or
your own sister don't do it to anybody
else's yeah so
it takes two obviously yeah tell me the
hadith please please for the brothers
are out there and they just have this
desire and you know what the same way
that that
brother came to the prophet saws and he
said that you know would you excuse me i
like to what do you say fornicate what
did the prophet how did he respond to
him yeah he said the same thing he says
i want to become a muslim but i you know
i have too much you know lost swims and
desires this sexual thing the urges uh i
can't give this up so of course the
companions may allah be pleased with all
of them who are angry and they wanted to
get names of prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi sallam has the art of dawa the
best way for propagation he knows how to
read people he knows the keys for every
personality so he says ask them the same
question he turned the table on him
something that he can relate to that's
something that's tangible he says would
you like anyone to do that to your uh to
your daughter you get angry would you
like anyone to do that to your to your
wife you got angry about your mother and
so on so he went down the list of the of
the female
members of his family says of course not
he says all of us are the same
so everyone that you're doing for
anybody else's sister
it must be you feel this is your sister
in islam how could you would you accept
that for somebody do it to your to your
member your family if you don't then
don't do it to anybody else's family
because it's a promise what you do will
be done unto you amazing amazing and
that's why islam is protecting the
family protecting the man and woman from
this corruption that's going on and who
knows best the creator of the heavens
and earth and marriage that's the key
you want to do it do it god's way do it
allah's way marriage and we're going to
come back to talk about when couples do
get married the halaway the permissible
way and then they have disagreements
it's normal it's something that happens
but how do you deal with it so you don't
break the home we'll be back with more
with shay ali here on the details sit
tight
to save one life is as if you've saved
all humanity
show kindness to your parents just as
they cared for you when you were young
give in charity of the good things you
earn
even a smile is a charity
explore the real values of islam call
toll free 877 why islam order your free
copy of the quran today
back here with sheikh allah and you got
a lot of experience we just talked about
just touched upon
what islam
and islam simply means is the same way
of life of all the messengers of god
that complete and total submission to
the one god the creator of all that
exists
and a muslim is one who does that action
of islam submitting his or her will to
the creator of heavens and earth and
he's laid out a whole system a game plan
from a to z how we need to conduct and
live our lives so we can have peace with
the crater and peace within ourselves
and peace with the environment and our
surroundings so marriage
when people do it the wrong way become a
statistic get using the views so now
people do it the right way and they get
married man and woman
conflicts start to happen
you have some kind of dramas
so fights we call them how can people if
they do fight is there such a thing as
fighting fair
of course there is and the uh
the real role model for us is prophet
muhammad
and before we even get there uh it would
be very naive to say that uh my marriage
is gonna be like a smooth sailing and
we're not gonna have fights the best of
creation prophet muhammad issues with
his wives may allah be pleased with all
of them and they were the best
so we have to keep things in perspective
but how to act
on it is important
we islam does recognize that you're
human being you get angry
it's normal if you actually live with
someone for a long time we're no angels
we have no halos on our head but we have
differences but how to turn these
negatives into positive and how to
celebrate the difference is very
important and the number one rule is you
have to understand the different
language that everybody speaks
so you have to recognize that you're
speaking to a woman and woman is emotion
as we mentioned before and the sister
has to understand that she's speaking to
a man and the man is physically based so
we have to decipher the hieroglyphics
between the two in order for us to
to use the prevention is better than
cure method we have to have this open
line of communication we have to
understand the different languages we
have to have a preventative measures we
have to look at the proactive analysis
we have to look at the root cause
analysis all these things are a lot of
things to to say with the few minutes
but if certainly uh hopefully we can
leave you with some of the keys that you
would be able to use in just in case
that you do have any arguments which is
normal in a marriage life what are some
of the do's and don'ts okay people get
in the fight and now you're praising the
creator of the heavens and earth with
your mouth you're getting a fight start
cursing is that for example i don't
right uh the brother he gets out of
control he can't handle the emotions so
now again he freaks out and he'll say
some things out of his mouth he
shouldn't say and mean things and then
it just creates a worse situation than
better so give us some example that
you've seen in the 20 years that you've
been dealing with these issues some of
the basic do's and don'ts absolutely
first of all before you actually get
into
any uh discussion i use the word
discussion
make sure
that you have a goal
before you sit down what is the purpose
what is the goal for this uh discussion
so if your goal is to prove that you're
right and everybody else is wrong
it's not a good start so we know that a
true believer stops where they find the
truth so you're there to do what to look
for the truth if you're if you're wrong
you have to submit to that we don't live
in denial we have to submit to this the
will of allah subhanahu wa
and what prophet muhammad
told us there is a list of do's and
don'ts so the first thing is to make
sure that you don't accuse
you don't go in there offending anyone
automatically the walls get up if i go
inside it's you that and and again we
know the the story behind the finger one
two or three three towards like looks
like gun so as soon as you start
accusing the opposite uh you know your
spouse you're basically putting the uh
the walls up and that's not the idea so
what we're looking for we're looking for
something that is uh to correct so it's
a behavior correction not the person
because you say i love you honey but
there is something about this behavior
that we need to change so you are good
but the behavior is unacceptable that is
a good start but as soon as we start
saying you are the one that doing this
it's automatic uh non-starter so that's
absolutely on the do not list when you
do so we'll do the opposite so el
morgelloff the knowledge of the opposite
if i say don't then the opposite is true
so when you sit down have a game plan in
mind a road map and make sure that you
have a something called kiss
keep it simple keep it simple keep it
simple so we don't have too many on the
agendas if a couple comes to me in the
office and they said you know i see the
red coming in their eyes and they're you
know they're they're posture they're
physical they want they want to go to
war i said okay sit down let's let's
talk about it and i gave him a piece of
paper and we do something called the
wheel of life and the lp that is like a
life coach you take him one step at a
time but first i ask him for one thing
and one thing only what is number one on
your list so let's work on priorities so
if you sit down with a couple first of
all says why are you here you must be
here for a reason okay so uh then they
tell me i'm here for one two three from
they start saying okay i put the stops
on i could please tell me the number one
on your list what would if you change
about this guy you would be happy the
number one thing if this guy does you'll
be happy i asked the brother the same
thing what if she does uh that would
change you'll be happy so they give me
one thing from there i tell them to stop
let's work on this first and let's put a
game plan i want you to be become the
part of the solution not the problem we
don't fish for faults everybody has
faults
but how can we help one another and the
key word here is the do's is to complete
one another do not
compete with one another this is a major
uh issue with our brothers and sisters
nowadays unfortunately everybody comes
with a scoreboard you know i do this he
does this it's not that yeah
it's how we can help one another it's
not because of this you know i'll do
that because shaytan plays against you
24 7. that's his job to break you up and
we know the hadith and when shaytan
comes in and says you know what she did
that to you what she means it doesn't
respect you respect and by the way
sisters number one on the man's list is
respect
if the man is not respected in a certain
place he doesn't want to be there
and number one on the sisters list is
love
that word that we can't say very much
even the best of creation said it
prophet muslim says
i was blessed by your love so we can
work on that inshaallah so these are the
some of the do's in the to do not since
allah will continue
we want people to code incredible people
like you people when you do have a
conflict you go to someone who's going
to try to push you to keep working
together and give us techniques advices
so should couples when they do are there
some do's and don'ts as soon as you get
an argument let's say the brother he's
going to you know his high school friend
to get advice and then the brother is
like man man why you just why are you
wasting your time i go get another or
she goes to the sister or even it could
be the in-laws you know the parents and
even when they have good intentions
they're not people who maybe will be
deducing you know the advice from the
quran the sunnah they end up even with
this good intention giving bad advice do
you see this happening is this a do or
don't absolutely but uh you have to
understand if you have a problem with
the car you go to a mechanic mechanic
right so please brothers and sisters you
know
you hear allah
your wife's taking a strange oath from
you
may allah be pleased with them and all
the sahaba the companions he says this
is the stringent oath that allah
subhanahu has taken
from what with the verse it says
hold them treat them with righteousness
deal with them in righteousness
because you have to understand that when
you say when you put the hand of the
guardian's hand you says i accept
marrying that sister according the quran
sunnah that's a strange an oath it's not
a lip service it's not words you say and
you see of her what her father didn't
receive her so this is this
that's the stringent part so we have to
fear allah subhanahu wa
and make sure that we treat them with
kindness so prophet muhammad says
with the vessels these are glass vessels
again going back to understanding the
differences that women are emotional so
you have to deal with that and make sure
that allah first and foremost is the one
that
overwatches you and deal with them
accordingly a child we're going to take
a break and god willing we'll be back
with more here in the d shall sit tight
whatever allah commands you to do you
need to do it
islam has tolerance and mercy and
compassion
to know that allah you know will forgive
you as long as you do what you need to
do as long as you turn back to him
islam is a system of mercy and
compassion and it is for the best
benefit of all of the people that's
around it muslim and non-muslims
back here on the dean show and we're
talking about fighting fair if you have
a fight
do it the right way the way that's gonna
inshallah god willing keep the family
together instead of breaking it apart
please continue on with some of the
device you were given ashay sure one
prophet muhammed
when he was stuck in
um
even he knew he recognized the fact that
even when allah
they raised them to do in their creation
decoration lurement they beautify
themselves but
when the when argument and quarrelling
they're emotional their defensive
mechanism is you know they start crying
and so on we're not generalizing of
course it's not to offend allah anyone
but the facts are there man is a little
more on the harsh side so when we do
this we know the prophet muhammad
took aisha off the hook when she
the story is is long but just to come to
the chase with the topic we're talking
about here when she was uh
walking after him to go to baker it was
her night and he came back found out it
was her you know she was doubting in
certain things she was jealous and
thinking that he was good to another and
so on he says that uh
do you not trust me and so on
for the just the paraphrasing of course
said now oh she knows that she's on the
hook so what happened she said right
away to change their mind do you want to
change the subject topic it says what do
i say or messenger of allah when i go to
that
the the grave or the cemetery he says
you say one two three he didn't say aha
you're trying to change your mind no
don't do that and and so on so he knew
that he was he wanted to give her a
break and make sure that we uh we do the
same thing and the most important part
if you want to discuss anything please
listen to uh
when she had
her son die
when her husband
was on a journey when he came back
even then she didn't tell him right away
so i'm telling the sisters please choose
the right time to discuss issues if
their husband is coming from from work
tired he doesn't have the mental
capacity he's not prepared the
environment is not right so please
choose the time and the place for it and
now of course the story is known but
just to remind ourselves that she came
up to him what she do she didn't tell
him right away it's not like uh how you
doing honey uh
oh yes welcome home your son died
so what did you say she beautified
herself
she lured the the she dim the lights she
prepared the food she had an intimate
relations with him in the morning
in the morning she told him give him an
example a parable that if somebody
entrusted us with
something that left with us and come and
ask for it our neighbor wouldn't we not
give it back so of course
lesson learned here that she knew now
what we talked about before the same
points that we're going back to a man is
a physical being so what did she do she
looked after his physical needs she
beautified herself
took the pain of hunger away the whims
and desires they had the intimate
relations lower the the the light so the
environment psychologically he's at ease
in the morning after everything and the
pain of unrest is taken care of she
paved the way nicely he was now ready to
uh to listen and understand and of
course the rest of it was history when
he told prophet muhammad
and so on and allah granted him a better
righteous child if anything people can
do now we're almost out of time so a lot
of these key points we're just brushing
upon it just a tad bit there's so much
more this topic is so important because
marriage i mean you got good homes you
can have good societies broken homes
broken societies so
you mentioned something go into a
mechanic if you have a car problem so
if people are at the edge now you know
what other and last closing comments and
advice for those people who are trying
they're having some difficulties
shaytan's there in the mix he's trying
to break the home so you can have broken
societies right should they run towards
their imam should they run towards the
scholars people who are going to try to
really give them these tips and advice
so they don't go towards you know
someone else who's given them wrong
advice right well first of all we have
our our goals as though first of all we
admonish like allah subhanahu ta'ala is
mentioned you know give him wisdom talk
to him nicely remind him of allah in the
quran
turn your back and the other option of
course is not it's not an option there
that you don't have to take or a garden
from her family or garden from your
family come an arbitrator see these are
issues that we can go through stages in
sha allah but first all make sure that
you look at the bag of your wife in the
bag of your husband look at the good
things that they have don't look at the
bad things nobody's perfect then look at
the good things they will always
outweigh the bad things don't tell her i
want to divorce her because i don't like
the way she combs her rabbit hair i
don't like the way she squish the
toothpaste these are the things that are
ma are irrational like
slapped the man when he came up to him
he says i want to divorce my wife his
wife says i don't fear love her anymore
what do you do you slap him do you think
that the homes are built just upon love
there's much more than that we have a
message we have a children we have a
goal we have our boat that we have to
get to safety in the boat in this life
is the trials you will have high winds
and high waves rest assured but work
together to get this boat to safety and
safety is janna
that's it that's it beautiful advice
thank you so much sheikh pleasure may
god almighty the creator of love reward
you you too thank you and thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the dean
show some wonderful advice some
wonderful advice
we want to keep the homes keep the
families together and not break them
apart that's the easy thing to do but
you got to work hard it's easy to break
bring something
up from the bottom whatever it is you
got to work hard towards making that
building easy to tear it down don't tear
apart your families go towards qualified
people counselors go towards turning
back to the quran and sunnah to the
creator of the heavens and earth
and live by these guidelines if you're
going to fight fight by the guidelines
that have been sent down from the crate
of the heavens and earth
and with that said we'll see you next
time here on the show until then peace
be unto you